Now if you recall from
the beginning of the lesson,
we talked about three major
ways to estimate value.
One is intrinsic value,
which we just covered.
Another is book value,
which we're going to cover now.
And the other is market capitalization.
So let's take a look at book value.
Here's a classic
definition of book value.
It's total assets of the company.
In other words,
things like property that is owned and
so on, minus intangible assets and
liabilities.
Intangible assets are things that
are difficult to put a price on.
They're things like the value
of a brand, or a pent, or so on.
Liabilities are a little
bit easier to calculate,
those are just things like
loans that are owed and so on.
So, let's consider what's the book
value for an example company.
Let's say that a company
owns four factories, and
that each of these factories
is worth about $10 million.
These are assets, and altogether
they are worth about $40 million.
Suppose this company also holds
three very important patents and
each patent is valued
at about $5 million.
The value of these patents
is about $15 million, but
these are intangible assets
that are hard to price exactly.
Finally, suppose this
company has one large loan.
This would be under the liabilities
column of $10 million.
If we follow this rule that
book value's total assets, so
total assets are this $40 million
plus the $15 million or $55 million,
minus intangible assets so we just
don't count these intangible assets.
And liabilities.
So all together we've got our total
assets minus intangible assets,
which is $40 million, and
liabilities minus this $10 million, so
in this case this company's
book value is $30 million.